Welcome to this
prep lecture
for OMM lab number 17.
Please take a
moment to review
these session objectives.
You have already
practiced constrain
from multiple
regions of the body.
And by this point,
you are already
familiar with its
general approach.
I've listed some
clinical pointers here.
Due to its gentle
nature, constrain is
very safe and versatile
when used properly.
It can often be
combined with other
techniques to enhance
results. For example,
because it is quite
effective at reducing
tension and
tenderness in the soft
tissues, it is an option
to use counterstrain
in order to prepare
tissues for HVLA in
order to enhance
comfort and efficacy.
I've listed here some
general indications
and contraindications
for counterstrain,
but this also applies
really to any OMT.
The list is by no
means all-inclusive.
The most important
things are to properly
evaluate the patient
through your medical
and structural
examination and approach
the patient through
a reasonable
differential diagnosis
with an understanding of
potential benefits
and risks, and then
of course communicating
this with the
patient so you can
obtain informed consent.
It is always a good
idea to inform patients
of what they may
experience after OMT.
Here is some advice
that is generally
given to patients
after they receive any
form of OMT, including
counterstrain.
Both this and the
following slide
lists the basic steps
of counterstrain.
I have also added
detail and bold
in order for
you to provide a
comprehensive and
effective technique.
Even though all the
steps might seem tedious,
they are quite logical
and one flows into
the next. So if you
approach it through
this lens, it should
make the memorization
piece more manageable
and with practice less
necessary because again
it is quite logical.
Please keep in mind that
with Counter-Strain,
practice in lab
because you will be
learning several points
and learning the various
treatment positions
there's not enough time
to go through the
full version with each
and every step however
you should do this
at least several times
on your own either in
lab as well as practice
outside of lab so
that you really
internalize these steps if
we take a moment to
look at step number two
when we monitor a point,
or when we diagnose
a point, excuse me,
and you decide if a
point is tender or not,
of course the patient
will give you feedback
if it's tender or
not. That's what you
would instruct the patient
to do, but there are
physical cues too.
Patients may react
to tenderness by
blinking their
eyes, grimacing, or
withdrawing the
body region that you
are pushing on.
So be aware of the
entire range of a
patient's responses.
You scale the point
as a 10 over 10.
This is not meant
to make the point
more tender
than it actually
is, unless of course
it is a 10 over
10, if it's really
that tender.
However, it's
really meant to give
both you and the
patient an easy starting
point, an easy
point to remember.
So sometimes people
describe it as a dollar's
worth or ten dollars
worth of pain and
you and the idea is
to get that number to
zero or the least amount
of pain we try for
zero it's not always
possible so that's
where the fine tuning
comes in so again the
steps make sense but
do review all these
steps on both this
slide and the following
to make sure that you
understand them here
are some additional
pointers for this lab.
Because pelvic
counter strain points
involve the use of the
lower extremities to
set up the treatment
physician, it is
particularly important
for you to keep in mind
proper ergonomics so
that you avoid straining
your back or arms and
the patient remains
relaxed and thereby
you can optimize
both comfort and efficacy
of the technique.
Please take a moment
to review these
various pointers
to make sure that
they make sense to
you so that you can
provide counter
strain effectively.
This diagram shows
the locations of the
anterior pelvic
counter strain points.
The four purple dots
represent the four
points you're
responsible for in this
lab. Because counter
strain is an indirect
technique and and
these are anterior
pelvic constrain
points, it makes sense
that the treatment
position of these
points involve some
degree of hip flexion.
And then there
are additional
details to accomplish
the treatment
for each of these points.
There are also anatomical
correlations of
these points. The
psoas constrain point
is thought to represent
the psoas major.
The low ilium constrain
point is thought to
represent the psoas
minor. These details
are found in your
handout and you are
responsible for learning
them for this lab.
Before performing
any type of HVLA,
it is important to
provide adequate
soft tissue technique.
You can choose
from among the
techniques listed here.
If the dysfunction
is mild, chances
are you will not be
choosing HVLA. It
does not mean you
can't. That depends on
your skill level
and of course a mild
dysfunction will
require less force.
When you provide soft
tissue technique, do
it with the intent of
reducing the tension
in the region of the
somatic dysfunction.
This will enhance
the efficacy of HVLA.
Once you proceed
to the setup for
HVLA, you will get
another chance at
sensing the barrier
that remains.
Remember, during
the setup,
one of the steps is
to, once you engage
at the barrier, is
to gently spring on
it. It is not required
that you spring
on it, but it often
is done because it
not only can help to
reduce the barrier
further, but will
also give the provider
an extra sense of how
much of restriction
remains for you
to thrust through.
When you set up the
technique, make sure
it's comfortable for both
you and your partner.
Make sure that the
table is at a good
height. Adjust it
accordingly to your height
and also make sure that
it's well time have
the patient breathe
in and during the
exhalation phase take
up the tissue slack and
once you reach as
close to the end of the
barrier meaning towards
the end of exhalation
then you will provide
a quick thrust but
keep it low amplitude
once that's done promptly
return your partner
to the neutral
position and reassess
the somatic dysfunction.
Here are two pictures for
HVLA for the nominates,
both an anteriorly
rotated nominate as
well as a posteriorly
rotated nominate.
Each picture
captures the moment
prior to the thrust.
As you can see,
the rotated nominate
is up towards
the provider or
towards the ceiling.
In each instance, the
patient's torso also
is turned from both
above and below in
order to vector into
the sacroiliac joint.
In the picture on
the left, one can see
how the arrow which
shows the vector
force is directed
in an anterior but
also inferior
direction, aiming down
towards the patient's
hip and leg region.
As you can summarize,
this is the setup
for an anteriorly
rotated nominate because
the The thrust is
aimed at rotating the
right anominate in a
posterior direction.
In the picture
on the right, the
arrow shows the
vector force aiming
in an anterior and
superior direction
towards the
provider's abdomen.
It is important to
realize that in both
instances, both for
anterior and posterior
anominate, that there
is proper contact of the
provider's forearm on
the patient's upper
buttock posterior iliac
crest region so that
there is enough of a
contact as the hand or
in this instance the
forearm should not
slide. Also the thrust
is high velocity and low
amplitude. In order
to accomplish this the
provider must have
the table set up at a
proper height and it
is important that the
patient is also close
enough to the provider.
Lastly, please be
sure that you do not
tiptoe as you perform
this maneuver, as you
should feel stable in
your own stance prior
to performing the
thrust on the patient.
Next, we have superior
nominate HVLA.
In this technique shown
for the right side,
note how the provider
is holding the
patient's right leg
proximal to the ankle
and also in a slightly
abducted position.
In the picture on the
right, the provider
is also bending
slightly at the knee and
leaning back somewhat
in order to optimize
ergonomics and ability
to exert sufficient
traction. The
traction during the
setup is enough to
localize to the region
and this is fine-tuned
by working with the
internal rotation
and abduction as
necessary to feel like
you have fully localized
to the region. The
thrust is then applied
in an inferior
direction towards the
provider using a quick
but short thrust.
Here we have
HVLA for a right
inferior nominate
shear. Note how the
provider's
forearm is placed
under the right
ischial tuberosity.
Note how the patient's
right foot is
placed behind the
knee. I know it does
not show that exactly
in the picture
here, but that's the
idea to so-called
park the foot in
the papateal fossa.
The vector of
force is going to
be aimed directly
cephalat,
meaning towards
the patient's head.
Here are some
important reminders
for diagnosing
the nominate
bones for somatic
dysfunction.
A complete somatic
dysfunction diagnosis
includes evaluation
of the *****
rami for any asymmetry
so that you can
make a separate
***** bone somatic
dysfunction diagnosis
if one is present.
With practice, you
should be able to
accomplish all of this
in under a minute.
To be efficient
at this, make sure
that you perform the
standing flexion test
correctly by
placing your thumbs
underneath the PSISs
and placing them firmly
there as the patient
bends forward.
Make sure that
your thumbs do not
slide over the
PSISs because
that can throw
your findings off.
Also, when you
check landmarks for
asymmetry in the pelvis,
make sure that you
name the side that is
superior or inferior
based on the side
of the positive
standing flexion test
if it is present.
When you examine the
landmarks between
the patient being
supine and prone, make
sure you reseat the
pelvis. You do this
by asking the patient
to bend at their
knees and place their
feet on the table
and then raise the
pelvis off the table
briefly and then
lower it back onto
the table. And then
you straighten the
legs and check for
the pelvic landmarks.
This ensures
that you are more
accurate in noting
any asymmetry.
This concludes this lab
prep lecture
for the pelvis.
Thank you for
your attention.